there we go okay
good morning
good morning morning class
i'm just laughing um whenever i see
rooms like this it's like i want to take
a register
you know bob isn't here where's bob
where's bob
um
so thank you very much first of all to
the organizers of nbc for inviting me
it's a massive pleasure to be back in
copenhagen it's a city i really love
denmark i really love i've spent quite a
lot of time in all of all places
which is a great city any people from
all over
um been to billings of course you have
to go to buildings
because reasons
um
and here i am in copenhagen yeah so
thanks very much uh jacob and the rest
of the ndc crowd so my name is james um
i'm going to be talking about this team
topologies
software architecture and complexity
science
so i hope you enjoy it
but first i thought i'd give you the
background on my t-shirt
so this is an email i got
from
jacob
uh says hi james how are you like woohoo
andy see you back in touch right
excellent uh microservices workshop for
oslo and london how about how about that
it was great maybe i could do
get back on the horse you know after the
pandemic
the aftertimes all right this is the
next line sam newman can't make it
to nbc oslo or ndc london
so
we're looking for a replacement any
chance i sent back literally this reply
so just to so that says turing's dead
martin fowler said no sam newman
couldn't make it
hi
so i'm wearing my t-shirt hi
i'm james lewis
morning
if you don't know who i am i'm the other
micro services guy right sam sam got to
write the book
but i got to go on a sleepover with
martin
where we wrote the original
uh the original set of uh
characteristics that we found from
microservices and in that
we said this
so we said we can't say there's a formal
definition of the microservices
architectural style all right what we
what we were trying to do with the
microservices definitions that were all
characteristics that we came up with is
harvest
a set of things that we saw
organizations doing and being successful
doing it right so
for example when we talk about you know
componentization by services netflix at
the time were talking about fine-grained
service-oriented architectures that was
the name they were talking about uh dan
north who is now daniel tillhorse north
he was an investment bank
commodities trader actually and they
were talking about replaceable component
architectures at the time and the
guardian newspaper group were also
talking about small services
and so on
come in class come in
there's a couple of seats at the front
over here actually there's three here
um so this is what we were sort of
trying to do is trying to look around
and see what was working
in the industry what was different about
about the sort of period 2010 to 2012
where this massive sort of explosion in
distributed system design was happening
why was it working why was it successful
and we tried to come up with a limited
set of characteristics which are these i
won't go through them all
because
um and probably you've probably seen
these sam's talked about them a lot
we've talked about them a lot
but what this talk is about it's not
microservices per se it's not software
architecture from with microservices per
se it's not about these characteristics
it's about my journey since then it's
about sort of 2012
2014 on to now it's about the things
i've been thinking about in my head
um
this sort of ongoing journey you know to
kind of watch the boldly go star trek
thing but the ongoing journey to kind of
understand
why is it that these were successful why
has the micro services architectural
style become the predominant
architectural style uh for for for now
really
so that's what this is about it's a it's
a keynote so it's supposed to be big
ideas i hope you're ready for some big
ideas there's gonna be some elephants
because why not
there's gonna be some shrews because
again why not the etruscan shrew is very
small
there'll be cities there'll be companies
there'll be teams there'll be software
architecture a whole bunch of stuff
but it is quite an abstract talk it's
kind of sort of out there talk so i
remember when i worked with dan north we
used to pair together at a an investment
bank in london um and he used to sort of
talk to me about chunking up in
abstractions
so you know when you're thinking that
the sort of level of methods are inside
the class you want to think about that
level of abstraction when you chunk up
to sort of thinking about groups of
classes maybe in a namespace you want to
think about that level of abstraction
and then you want to chunk up again to
groups of namespaces maybe libraries you
want to think of that and you chunked up
again to maybe a service and chunk up
again to maybe maybe a domain about it
context and maybe then you chunk it up
again to
business capabilities that's what this
is about it's about sort of chunking up
it's about seeing the sort of what
levels of abstraction we might be able
to think about that underlie
these characteristics
so i hope you enjoy it
what we'll talk about first though is
the fact that underpinning a lot of this
is the thing i noticed
is this idea of decentralization right
of small things communicating via by
uniform interfaces and you know pushing
responsibility for things like decision
making and governance and data
management down to the people who know
the most so teams down to individuals on
teams rather than having decision making
done in an ivory tower somewhere where
you have to kind of wait for responses
and all this kind of stuff
so you know decentralization of data
pushing things like data mesh these days
that's that's the sort of the end result
if you like of thinking in terms of
microservices having you know data
products owned by the same teams that
own the microservices so
decentralization
that's what got me thinking
about the rest of it
but what i'm going to start with as i
promised
is this idea of
team topologies now
it's early in the morning it's earlier
for me because you know hours behind all
that uh
but put your hand up if you've read team
topologies
put your hand up if you've even heard of
team topologies
ah interesting this is going to be new
for you then
which is great so team topologies is a
book written by two
two folks in the in london who are very
sort of active and have been active
members of the continuous deliveries of
devops
community in london
um it's it's a brilliant book because
what it does is it gives us
indeed terms a ubiquitous language
to talk about how our teams work how we
structure our teams around building
software and the different types of
teams that you can encounter when you're
looking to build software and to
optimize your organization for faster
delivery of software for improving flow
so that's what the book is i've got a
reference to it in a minute
i'll just give you a brief overview of
team topologies
but first i want to take you back a few
years
this is to my job is terrible you know i
fly out here i just keynote i get a nice
hotel it's very nice thank you very much
ndc
this is a quote
from uh someone i know at amazon aws in
particular when i was at a workshop on
the lovely caribbean island of anguilla
there's an open space unconference
in the caribbean which i go to roughly
every year i used to
paul james you're playing poor james in
the caribbean every year
but we were at this workshop and there
was an interesting interesting group of
people there that that year one of whom
was melvin conway
of conway's law fame so mel conway you
know he's actually real he does exist
he's getting on a bit has to be said
he's sort of you know 80 or so these
days but still very active in thinking
he's a really active thinker still
around sort of philosophy of software
and how to build software but he was at
this at this event
and uh we had a session one afternoon
about about conway's law and how we'd
used conway's law
and there were some from netflix there
who said well in netflix what we do is
we sit teams according to conway's law
right so we have you know the ux team uh
they sit next to the platform api team
and then the you know the microservices
team sit behind that and then we've got
some ops teams sitting behind that and
all the way over there is cassandra and
that because the ux people don't really
need to talk to the cassandra people
right
so we optimize how we sit people in the
building very different this is the
before times how we sit people in the
building according to who they need to
talk to most right
so the optimizer and conway's law
conway's law is this idea that you know
your team structure will be reflected in
the architecture that you build or vice
versa the architecture
the software architectural design of
software is influenced by the structure
of the teams of the people building it
so you can optimize for that and milk on
my he's like oh my god there's this
massive company in silicon valley i
wrote this paper in 1968 or something
like this
you know and now they're organizing
themselves according to my according to
this random paper
um
what do you think you know it's like i
just wrote this thing a long time ago i
think it was build stuff was in um
a couple of years ago was the first time
he was invited sort of i came out of
retirement to go to build stuff to talk
but there was someone else there from
amazon from aws and they said something
interesting about conway's law they said
this the bigger we get
the easier it becomes to get bigger
right so for amazon for aws in
particular
as they get bigger it's easier to get
bigger
as they add more products it's easier to
add more products as they add more teams
it's easier to add more teams
in fact to the limit the guy said
in fact
we are only limited in terms of our
scaling by the number of people we can
hire
right if we could hire everyone in this
room we could now then build another
sort of 30 products bang
without worrying about scaling effects
i think
that's that's slightly unusual isn't it
i'll take a step back from that remember
that take a step back and talk about
organizational design briefly so i think
the goal of successful organizational
design right is to optimize the flow of
value right everything else is
subordinate to that
right when you think about any
organization whether it's manufacturing
whether it's retail whether it's what we
do in knowledge work whether it's being
a lawyer it doesn't really matter what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis is
optimizing the flow of value from
somewhere to somewhere else whether it's
oranges from seville to my tabletop at
home so i can eat them whether it's
requirements from someone in
in the businesses head into production
where i can make money
right whether it's a legal case
progression through the course it's
about flow it's about moving
stuff
through a series of steps optimizing
those series of steps and the successful
organizational design
and i would therefore argue for what we
do
via conway's law successful
uh software architecture or enterprise
architecture
the purpose is to optimize the flow of
value
i really like this quote from daniel
turtlesnorth
our goal on teams when we're building
software should be to safely and
sustainably reduce the lead time
to thank you not to value to thank you
to someone actually saying i'm using
your thing thanks thanks for that
as opposed to what the hell have you
done here teams
sorry
did i just say that out loud
but that um
three people laughed that's good maybe i
should have said what the hell have you
done here microsoft teams and then that
would have got a bigger light yeah um
but that does bring
to the floor this idea of what is value
what do we mean when we say value
well as i say it's stuff
everything is valuable right when we
think about lean manufacturing what we
talk about in a manufacturing process is
going from something that has minimal
value raw materials
to something that has progressively more
value as you pass it pass it through a
series of machines creating widgets
which get used by other machines to
build better widgets until finally you
get affinity a car
and the car has value and you buy the
car and you drive around and it's great
but that's that's the stuff right it's
just stuff moving through a value stream
and what we do the interesting thing
about what we do is the stuff we do
the stuff we use it's generally
invisible
right this is one of the real
realizations that i had reading a book
called the principles of product
development flow by donald weinerson is
that the stuff we work on
is invisible
if you're in a factory right and you're
looking at stuff you're looking at your
machines you know when something's wrong
because stuff piles up if a machine
breaks
loads of stuff piles up behind it right
because you can't push it through the
machine
how do we know that how do we know if
our processes are breaking well what we
do and i'll do a talk on this tomorrow
is to use things like you know kanban
boards to visualize the flow of stuff
that's really what we're doing when
we're using
you know storyboards and this kind of
thing and writing user stories is
visualizing invisible
stuff invisible value
so basically in my mind physical stuff
knowledge stuff they're pretty much the
same
it's just information in one form or
another whether that's physical or
whether that's you know digital or
whatever it is or in your head moving
through a value stream getting
progressively more valuable
you get raw materials an idea
some iron ore and then you it turns into
a thing right
but then the question is how long does
stuff take now this is from a
client i won't mention who i work for
consultancy i've spent a lot of time
with our clients this is this is a value
stream map of how their integration team
works
so in the middle
does my laser work
yeah not yet just about in the middle
this is the integration team here if you
can see that
see that over there lasers
that's the integration team
that blue card there
over this side this blue card there
that's writing code
that's it
right
write code it says on that card and this
is event we event storm this
all the rest of it
all the rest of these process steps
all right that's taking you know one
thing turning it into another thing
turning it into another thing turning it
into sometimes reversing the process and
turning it back into the thing it was
before because that thing was broken
right turning it into another thing
we've got a loop in here the loop is
brilliant the loop is where two types of
data architect who each had their own
canonical model
just went around in circles updating
each other's model
for about four weeks and they went yep
we're done now you can write code the
little bit right that tiny bit that's
writing code
how long does stuff take
this is a 200 year old organization this
is a very old company right this
company's been around a long time
they've accrued processes they've
accrued
a lot of stuff that they need to do you
know there's an integration testing step
here you know probably at some point
it's a retailer on black friday ten
years ago there was a problem and so
they said we must do eight weeks of
integration testing or regression
testing every time
and suddenly if you want to make a tiny
change the fastest you can get into
production is eight weeks
that kind of sucks right
you sort of accrue all these processes
and constraints over time
back to team topologies this is the book
so yeah emmanuel pison and matt skelton
what they've done is it's kind of a
matter study they've taken all this sort
of interesting work over the last
i would say 15 years around teams and
all structures and microservices and
conway's law and they've put it into one
place
and we can use it as a great reference
now
for how we build our teams
these are the teams they talk about they
talk about four fundamental team
topologies streamer line teams
so a streamlined team is one ideally
with a uh with with a view of the
customer right that operates on a single
value stream
so if you think you're building a
website you might have a streamlined
team around your checkout process or
your basket and they do everything end
to end
you might have a
a team aligned around your catalog page
or search right independent teams
building independent products
right with with their own view of the
customer you then have enabling teams
complicated subsystem teams and platform
teams you can think of the enabling team
as how do you make the best use of
limited resources right so if you think
about people like your awesome security
folk or devops people
or ux user research folk
you know those folks you've never got
enough to go around right there's never
enough to have one on every team as much
as we'd like
you you create these enabling teams and
they can act as consultants out into the
rest of the organization and they dip in
and out of teams when necessary then you
have maybe i don't know there's a really
scary risk management system that only
four people
who know the mainframe know about
that's a complicated subsystem team
and then the platform team platform
engineering teams whose job it is to
make the rest of the of the teams go
faster they provide things like build
and release pipelines you know um
observability stuff they might do chaos
engineering whatever it is and these are
pretty much the four team topologies
that you need in an organization in a
software development organization in
order to go as fast as possible
so that's my first first bit
so there's a
danish comedian in the uk very famous in
the uk called sandy togsvig
have anyone come across sandy thomasvig
yeah some she prevent presents a very
popular tv show called qi at the moment
and she tells this story about the first
time she did stand-up comedy going back
to scandinavia and she says i did 20
minutes
i thought it was pretty good material
she said
but everyone in the room was just
looking at me
blank
and i got to the end and everyone like
gave me this massive round of applause
and i said afterwards to the organizers
what was happening there he said oh we
really enjoyed it but we were just too
polite to uh to interrupt you you know i
thought that was so are we all okay at
the moment
all right you're not being too polite to
interrupt okay good right
right
so the next bit
the next bit is about software
architecture as i said i think in my
mind software architecture and
organizational design they are pretty
much the same thing right when we think
about team topologies we think about you
know how we structure our teams we
should be structuring the software the
same way right that those teams are
building
i'll take you back to this quote the
bigger we get the easier it becomes to
get bigger to the limit
you know it's just hiring that slowing
us down at aws
then i thought well that's not my
experience of most organizations right
this is my experience of most
organizations adding manpower to a late
software project makes it later right
this is the classic you know fred brooks
paper mythical man month uh we talks
about the fact that as you add people to
a software project you basically
increase the amount of overhead from
from communication you increase the
number of communication pathways and
eventually the number of people the
amount of computing
communication you have to do
overwhelms the benefits you get from the
additional capacity
that's my under that's like like this
everyone knows this right this is like
just the truth
so why is it that amazon or aws
are able to get around this
so i thought and by the way i warn you
pseudographs are a thing in this
presentation so pseudograph number one
coming up
for the data scientists please don't
shout at me
um there's five how many six points
one two three four five six
six data points i could find on this so
when i was looking at this this is a log
blog graph of um of amazon's size in
terms of the number of people they
employ versus the amount of revenue
they're making over time
right and that straight line we don't
really care about that y equals what we
care about is that 1.15 that exponent
means that amazon are growing faster
revenue faster than than they should
right in general i'll come to why in a
minute companies tend to uh scale
their revenue less than the number of
employees so if you double the size of a
company you don't double the amount of
revenue you make that's just a thing
but amazon are doing better than that
they're more than doubling their revenue
as they're adding more people like if
you like if you think about it one
adding one person means 1.15 worth of
worth of revenue
as they had one person
so how can that possibly be the case
and the interesting thing is when you go
back to 2004 was it jeff bezos wrote
this you know this memo
around you know how we're going to work
in the future in amazon as we move away
from you know big centralized databases
if we're going to move to these uh
independent teams and so on he said a
few things he said teams must
communicate via interfaces none of this
talk into each other's database etl
stuff and admittedly right if there's
people from amazon in the room i know it
took about 30 years to get there so you
know
but still
teams must communicate via interfaces
those interfaces must be externalizable
which means we must be able to sell
those to other people right
and this is where aws came from
externalizable interfaces that their
internal teams were using that were able
to be sold on to us as consumers
and then finally we're going to organize
around smallish teams right
smallish teams building these services
using externalizable interfaces and
that's how our teams communicate
and what i think these are he came up
with a number of forcing functions for
improving the flow of work within amazon
right
so limiting interactions to nearby teams
if i don't need to talk to you why do
why am i sitting next to you i sit
somewhere else i just sit next to the
people who i really need to talk to on a
day-to-day basis
you know isolating those teams
these externalizable interfaces
and then scaling by something called
dunbar's number
so in terms of software architecture
when amazon moved from their big
centralized systems to what is now a
sort of distributed system or set of
distributed systems and aws followed
that
and made that sort of infrastructure
available to the rest of us that was
because of these forcing flight
functions to improve flow within amazon
not for any other reason
it was to improve flow
they built a software architecture that
enabled them to go if you like as fast
as
possible but i did sort of say at the
start that i wanted to talk about why
right the underlying abstractions
and that's what the third part of this
is about
so complex adaptive systems causes
complexity science
it's a bit early for it
but it's a fun topic right so complex
adaptive systems which of the ideas
behind these were developed out of the
santa fe institutes in uh new mexico a
bunch of folk from los alamos including
like murray girl man a bunch of nobel
prize winners we're intrigued by how
from very simple things like atoms you
could get very complex things like
jaguars in fact he wrote a book from the
quark and the jaguar about this topic
how do you get stuff that's as complex
as us from stuff that's as simple as our
constituent parts
so here's a question
or here's a here's an interesting fact
rather it's about mice and elephants
what do mice and elephants have in
common
and us
well
we've got roughly the same number of
heartbeats in our lifetime as a mouse
and an elephant
we also have the same blood pressure
as a mouse and
an elephant
we share these
common
factors right
what changes between mice elephants and
us almighty us and elephants is the rate
at which our heart beats
right an elephant's heart beats really
really slowly in comparison to us and
our heart beats really slowly in
comparison to a max
and the reason that the reason that um
is essentially when you've got things
that you need to conserve like clyburt's
law which is the number of um uh beets
per
per mammal in their lifetime or blood
pressure something else needs to change
and it's the the rate at which the heart
beats that changes
what it means is that the bigger the
mammal
the slower they
live the slower their metabolic rate
what this graph shows is as you double
the size of a mammal you don't need to
double the number of calories that they
would that they need to take in in order
to survive
roughly an elephant needs about 75
percent of the calories you think it
should need as you double the size of a
mammal you only need 75
of the calories
because the metabolic rate of an
elephant is much slower than us
elephants don't get cancer bizarrely
their metabolic rate so so their cells
don't divide enough
to really get
the mutations that cause cancer they
operate really slowly metabolic rates in
mammal they follow the mammals they
follow the scaling law
with this exponent of three over four as
you double the size of a mammal
you only need 75 of the calories
well there's other examples of complex
adaptive systems out there
like news agents and giant department or
giant
supermarkets right
i mentioned about doubling the size of a
company doesn't double the revenue well
this is the figures from nasdaq that
were available
as you double the size of a company you
don't double the revenue within arrows
this is about three over four so about
the same as uh as the scaling factor for
metabolic rate in models a bit more
research it actually comes out at about
0.85 so as you double the size of a
company you get about 85 percent of the
revenue you should right
based on figures from the
listed companies on the exchanges
another example two cities that are
roughly double in size
what do they have in common
well as you double the size of a village
to a town tangible city city to a bigger
city it's a giant city to a mega city
you don't have to spend as much money as
you might think
on infrastructure
so for example road length petrol
stations restaurants these
number of water the amount of water
pipes this sort of thing you don't have
to double the number of water pipes as
you double the size
of a city
in fact it scales roughly
the same as uh
as as organizations revenue does not by
eight five
so you have these three different
examples of scaling laws from three very
different things cities companies and
mammals all right 0.85 0.85 0.75 but the
key thing here is that they're less than
one as you double the size of a thing
you don't you know double the size of
the other thing
this is a quote from the book scale i've
got the references at the back of this
at the end of this talk so um they'll be
available but in scale is a fantastic
book and jeffrey west the main author he
writes
quantities that do not change when other
parameters of the system change they
play a special role in science when we
see straight in other words when we see
straight lines somewhere we should
probably go and have a look why and
investigate what's going on because
there might be something underlying that
we've missed up until now
and what these straight lines on those
graphs mean well they've got a very
particular meaning in economics so in
economics you have different types of
scaling right different types of scaling
laws you have linear scaling as you
double one thing you get double
the other thing this is kind of
exponential growth you then get sub
linear this is by the way i should point
out these are all log log
you get sublinear scaling as you double
the size of one you don't double the
size of the other thing and this is
known as economies of scale this is when
our you know our cfos are banging on
about oh we need economies of scale
we'll get bigger and economies of scale
and we'll acquire that company because
economies of scale this is what they
mean
this is technically what the economists
mean by this
and underlying all of this
is this idea of complexity right these
three different types of complex
adaptive systems
and the properties of characteristics of
complex adaptive systems there's
basically four of them the first is
complex adaptive systems are
self-similar right so they're built up
from self-similar parts
we are built up from cells and
underlying that from atoms but we are
the same as a mouse or an elephant we're
built up from the same self similar
things which are cells
cities are the same they're built up
from the same self similar things houses
with people in them companies are the
same people doing work
self-organized
complex and active systems are
self-organized there's no central
coordinating agent that tells my body to
grow into james right it sort of self
organizes into james over time
they're complex like the whole is
greater than the sum of the parts if you
put me through a blender
you couldn't put me back together again
right that's pretty much i mean you'd
have all the same stuff
but you know james would not come out if
you smashed the blender together into a
james shaped mould
there wouldn't be thinking going well
you might argue there's not thinking
going on at all but hey
and then this idea of emergent behavior
so if you run the same thing twice if
you have two similar you know two
similar scenarios every time those
scenarios play out you're likely to get
a different answer right
so emergent behavior
underlying these four characteristics
mathematically are three simple
principles
the first one is this idea of fractal
networks a space filling
fractal network i'm showing you an
example of a hierarchical one here
hierarchical fractal network think in
our bodies our circulatory system that
is a space-filling fractal network that
takes nutrients from basically um you
know from
that allows nutrients to pass
finally through from our blood into our
capillaries to feed ourselves a
space-filling fractal network water
pipes in a city are a space-filling
fractal network you get a big water pipe
at the you know coming in well more than
one coming into a city it branched down
branch down branch down until you turn
on your tap that the pipe is the same
size and water comes out of the tap
all right space filling fractal networks
and the same um the same with with
organizations information pathways
information flow through organizations
form this space filling fractal network
they also if you think about it things
like network connections and
you know that kind of like information
flow in terms of infrastructure you need
that's also a space filling for actual
network
then we have this idea of invariant
terminating units so in our body those
are the essentially capillaries and then
the cells
in cities those are things like the taps
or the pipes that hit the taps and water
comes out into your house that's the
house is this is the
is the
invariant terminating unit in a company
it's basically people i've been trying
to get thoughtworks
rather than calling us
consultants to call us in variant
terminating units
but actually they prefer meat bags which
is annoying but you know hey what can
you do and then the third thing you need
is optimization of some sort
now in companies and cities that's
market forces that's how cities and
companies operate
optimize and in mammals it's
evolution
operating on evolutionary time scales
this feedback mechanism which turns us
from single cellular organisms into what
we are today increasingly complex things
as i say they're everywhere complex
adaptive systems are all around us the
teams we sit in the companies we work in
the cities we live in and ourselves are
all complex adaptive systems and can all
a lot of behaviors can all be described
with those simple properties
so those scaling rules mathematically
pop out
just
if you do the math
on those three simple properties
but the key thing here to take away from
this little bit is that hierarchies
anything anytime you see a hierarchical
fractal network it implies scaling with
a power law with an exponent less than
one it means every time you see a
hierarchy you don't get as much out as
you might think
you don't double the thing when you
double the other thing
right so
anytime you've got a blood circulatory
system that means as you scale me
the circulatory system scaling means
i don't need as many calories as you
scale
same with uh with companies as you scale
a company they don't need as many
network cables randomly but they also
don't get as much revenue out
and that's due to the hierarchy
basically lots of things of different
sizes they're pretty much the same thing
if you squint and look at them from 20
000 foot
which brings me on to this idea of
metabolism
why does revenue growth slow as size
increase
why is it that metabolic rates slow as
size increases what is it about these
things that cause that
and it's to do with the way
the networks
fit together the hierarchies go from
bigger things into smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller
things so for us we've got a heart on
our iota and then the arteries they
branch in branch and branch and branch
until eventually they reach a capillary
and the difference between an artery and
a capillary is
size and
there's no pulse in a capillary right
it's the oh it's lost
there's a continuous flow of
there's a continuous flow of blood
through the capillaries whereas in the
arterial system you're pumping basically
the heart is pumping blood through it
that's the difference between the
invariant terminating unit bit and the
the arterial bit if there wasn't a
continuous flow there wouldn't be time
essentially for nutrients to leak out
across the capillary boundary and for
our cells to be able to use those
nutrients the oxygen et cetera et cetera
right
it's down to the hierarchies
if you think about in in a city water
pipes go from this kind of like pumped
basically you've got massive pumps
somewhere pumping stuff through these
big pipes until eventually you get
continuous flow out and when you turn
your tap on and this is down
interestingly to how our these fractal
networks have evolved in us and how well
basically uh turbulent flow works um you
know if you think about a messaging
system right
and you've got a consumer of messages
and that consumer of mess or two
consumers of messages and you've got one
producer
right and the producer is operating at a
rate
faster or producing messages faster than
the two consumers
can consume them what
happens and messages back up right
not able to process them fast enough
well the same thing happens actually in
the circulatory system
we've optimized evolution has optimized
us when you go from an artery of one
size to two they are exactly the same
cross-sectional area
the reason being if they weren't blood
would rebound off the boundary putting
back pressure up the circulatory system
up the hierarchy
to the heart
putting pressure on the heart this is
where heart attacks come from this is
why plaque is so bad right when you
narrow the size of an artery
you've no longer got the right crosses
cross sectional area you get turbulent
flow at the boundary impedance
mismatching and bang
suddenly clark over and die which is not
very nice
i'll come on to corporate uh
well why companies die in a moment
but fundamentally hierarchies and this
flow of stuff through them
it's all about this idea of hierarchies
the flow of information through them and
these invariant terminating units at the
bottom
funnily enough
you know if you look at a blue whale and
an etruscan shrew which is about the
size of my thumbnail
they're the same thing the only
difference from a mathematical
perspective is the number of splits in
the arterial in their blood in their
blood supply in their arterial system
the number of the depth if you like of
the hierarchy
in fact interesting screw is so small
that it's pretty much got an up it's got
it's got it's basically heart
iota
artery capillaries pretty much but you
need to have at least one artery because
you need to pump blood
and a blue whale's just got lots of them
so bigger animals essentially are more
efficient because of the depth of their
the hierarchies of their fractal
networks their hierarchies sorry the
depth of their circulatory systems makes
them more efficient it means that they
have a slower metabolic rate
it basically pops out and this is due to
impedance matching in the circulatory
system and that's driven by feedback
from evolution
bigger companies are also more efficient
so when people say economies of scale
it's actually a real thing as you double
the size of a company you don't need to
spend as much on it on infrastructure on
the things that are hierarchical network
cables water pipes all that stuff right
an office that's twice as big is more
efficient than the one half its size
but they also from an information flow
perspective they develop deeper
hierarchies as they age
so as a company gets older the length of
time it takes information to flow from
one place to another gets longer
and this is why the revenue scaling is
the same
and this is driven by market forces
and they both slow down as they age as
well
on to my next bit flow so i mentioned
value stream maps earlier so if you
think about a hierarchy in an
organization in a company
and you think about a value stream map
it's pretty much a slice through your
organizational hierarchy it's a slice
from where the work is imagined to come
from and where the work ends up being
done and put into production and earning
money
it's a slice through that information
hierarchy and funnily enough if you look
at most value stream maps lots of
interesting things pop out things like
queues jira tickets
all right i want to get a database let's
raise tickets okay we're moving away
from that age now which is thankfully
but still lots of tickets backlogs lots
of queues i need to go to the change
request boards to get something approved
the architectural review board needs to
approve this
lots of cues of stuff and what those
cues are
is the equivalent of plaque in your
artery every time you put a cue into an
information flow what you're doing is
you're deliberately
pausing the flow of information you're
putting back pressure on the corporate
uh the corporate heart rate if you like
slowing things down
this book principles of product
development flow talks a lot about why
cues are bad so don reilly said i
mentioned earlier he's a he's a genius
he's an awesome dude he talks about the
economics of flow the economics of how
um of of of
of what we do information you know
information work
working knowledge work what am i talking
about
and in this he talks about cues and why
queues are bad you know for example the
longer something
like stage of the queue the longer your
cycle time if you've got a really deep
cue the thing at the bottom will take a
long time to get into production and so
on and so on and so on
so
this book is brilliant
the next bit is about corporate
metabolism so
as i say to summarize rather as
companies scale they add more and more
processes and hierarchy and things slow
down
but we also deliberately block our
corporate arteries by doing things like
in putting cues in place stopping
deliberately stopping the information
flow
so this is a bit of a sidebar um it
wouldn't be a keynote keynote without
talking about accelerate
so accelerate amazing book one of the
most
i think one of the most important books
about what we do again has been written
in the last 10 years
this is the summary of the state of
devops reports talks about how you can
measure
uh the health of an organization by
looking at four key metrics they're all
there you can measure organizational
performance
just by looking at four key metrics or
you can see the trends in them
in this in the research behind
accelerate they find i'm going to choose
my words very precisely that change
request boards predict
low organizational performance
they don't correlate with low
organizational performance if you have a
change request board it predicts you
will be a low performing organization
that's kind of interesting isn't it
how many of you've got those
architecture review boards the same
they're predictors
so the interesting thing is though from
accelerate what they give you is these
four key metrics
right so mean time to recovery there's a
fifth now which is reliability but
meantime to recovery cycle time change
failure rate and the number of deploys
and these things are the equivalent of
going to our doctor and say i don't feel
very well they take your heart rate
think your blood pressure take your
temperature
these 4k metrics are are a sign of
organizational performance they're a
sign of whether you're getting older as
a company worse performing
slower slowing down whether your
metabolic rate is slowing down or
whether you're going faster
so these four key metrics they're
leading indicators of organizational
health like you know going to get a
checkup from the doctor
so we should work to as dan north says
we should work to you know safely and
sustainably improve these things right
improve the lead time to thank you
but the problem is
any improvement is limited if you're in
a hierarchy
hierarchies will always limit you to
growth that's
less than exponential to sublinear
growth
companies die sorry to tell you this
organizational mortality is the next bit
it gets better
why do companies die and it turns out
they do quite a lot the half-life of the
exchange of a company on the exchanges
is about 10 years so every 10 years 50
percent churn
on the stock exchange most in most stock
stock exchanges right it's half life is
about 10 years
you can't tell which ones
but statistically
you know companies die all the time they
get taken over they go bankrupt
acquired
why is it that that companies die why do
companies die these complex adaptive
systems like
we die
where cities don't
well it seems and there's less research
here because you know it's a bit less
open there's a lot of open research
around cities around things like
biology
companies a bit more private turns out
but it seems that if you look at the
proportion of
money you spend on r d
as a proportion of your overall budget
as you get bigger you spend less
than you should if you like
in the same way as we get older once
companies get older and bigger as we get
older and my case bigger
have to spend more energy on repairing
my cells than i do on creating new ones
for example right that's what agent is
really and companies do the same thing
except it's manifest in a different way
manifest is spending less on the thing
that made them great to start with they
spend less on developing new products
less invention less and research and
development and more on sort of
maintaining a steady state more on
reducing costs this kind of thing more
on adding processes and in constraints
until you end up with these giant valley
streams which are giant hierarchies if
you turn them
like that
so what you end up with as companies age
is these hierarchies they grow and grow
and grow with more and more
constraints but hierarchies hierarchical
organizations they gain economies of
scale for infrastructure right so this
is a good thing this is our cfos are
right about this
uh an office twice the size is more
efficient than an office half of its
size but
they achieve sublinear growth in revenue
that's just the math
that's just the physics behind it you
get 85 percent of the revenue as you
double in size
and eventually they die which sucks
but there is some good news because
there's a different type
of fractal network that we can look at
and there's different types of scaling
laws as well so there's a different type
of thing called returns to scale returns
to scale is when you double the size of
one quantity you more than double
the size of the other quantity again
this is log law as x increases y
increases by more than it
should and cities have both returns to
scale
and economies of scale
so they have returns to scale for
socioeconomic factors innovation wages
number of professionals crime something
that's very relevant at the moment
disease growth and spread
it grows faster in a bigger city than it
does in a smaller city more than it
should if you like
so the socioeconomic factors they
display this returns to scale
whereas for things like road length as i
said already you get economies of scale
right this is why cities are so
successful
as you double the size of a city you
have to spend less on stuff less petrol
stations less roads less lighting
less water pipes but you get more out in
terms of the amount of wages that people
earn all this socioeconomic stuff you
get more than you should
oh i've gone back rolling forward
also
fun fact walking speed
walking speed also gets faster as you
double the size of this is they did
research mit had mobile phone data which
they analyzed as you double if you go
from like a village to a town
people walk 110 percent faster because
they will move 10 10 faster than they
should rather you know in in the town um
you know obviously
obviously in london we haven't got like
exoskeleton legs to enable this but you
know hey
so what is it that's driving these
returns to scale these super the super
linear growth aspect it's this idea of
small world fractal space filling
networks a different type
of fractal space filling network
basically social networks so if you look
at your network of friends and family
that's a social network if you look at
the people you know in the city in which
you live that's a social network with
more or less well-connected nodes and so
on
and social networks are this driver
they're the thing that drives this type
of loosely connected
social network drives super linear
growth
i mentioned you know dunbar's number
earlier
um you know two pizza teams well two
pizza teams is essentially around the
dunbar's number of about 15 there's more
than one dumbass number
so this is based on a bunch of research
around the number of people that you
know the number of social connections
you can sort of keep in your head
essentially
to paraphrase it
and they you know they grow in different
sizes so the smaller one number five
number five is the the number of
connections that are your closest
connection so my nuclear family you know
it's awkward because um i've got six in
my nuclear family so it's my wife and me
and four kids so it means i either love
my wife less or one of the kids and
that's just maths but hey you know
i haven't told them that
then it scales up to you know the number
of people um in your you know in your in
your you know your closer family and
then your very close friends and then
your acquaintances and so on
dunbar's number scaling by dumbell's
number uh as as uh jeff bezos sort of
said two pizza teams because then you
know everyone we used to do this in four
weeks we used to open new offices we
stopped doing it so much every time we
got to dunbar's number of about 150 200
because that's the number of people who
whose faces you really recognize
you know who you can i can say how was
the golf trip
or whatever you did you know how was the
lego building thing you did
that would be me you got warhammer for
me but hey yeah but there's there's a
number of people that you know really
well you can hold these conversations
with and every time we got to that
number we'd create a new office we'd
split off and start a new office that's
why we've got three in the uk we've got
i don't know eight or nine in india
rather than one big one because we're
trying to scale around these social
networks the social effects
so what i'm trying to get to here is
you've got options right
in terms of how we structure ourselves
our organizations and therefore our
software architectures
we could structure around hierarchies
which are going to give you economies of
scale means you get less out than you
might want
or we can structure around small worlds
small worlds social networks
and then you get more right than you
think
and if you think about it it's kind of
obvious because you know how do you grow
a small world network well how do you
grow a hierarchy with a hierarchy you've
got to sort of
add more layers or you've got like
squeeze layers it's like computer
science
you know data structures 101 where you
have to kind of work out how to expand a
kind of you know a graph structure it's
just a nightmare right no one like doing
that much easier just to add a new node
on the side
which is what smaller networks do
in cities you know you add a new suburb
you add a new little housing state on
the side you convert some brownfield
site into a new uh into a new part into
a new part of the city you add stuff on
the edge
and interestingly you can measure the
health
of these networks by measuring something
called the fractal dimension so you can
measure how crinkly the boundary is
of a fractal of a small fractal network
it'll tell you how healthy it is detroit
when it was going through its sort of
decline in the set of 80s and 90s the
fracture how crinkly the edge of detroit
was the fractal dimension decreased
and now it's increasing again as it's
becoming more healthy
we do the same thing with our groups of
friends our twitter you know the people
connected to us on twitter and so on
so you add these bits on the side
so to summarize this bit
as cities grow
you get economies of scale for
infrastructure you don't have to spend
as much as you might think on water
pipes and so on
but you get returns to scale for
socioeconomic factors like wage growth
number of lawyers
we always need more lawyers right
that's fun fact we were in a dispute
with a giant company once about being
paid for because reasons and think we
couldn't really like like progress
legally because they had more lawyers
than we had people
we actually had one person whose job it
was for a whole year to try and get that
cash but anyway that's another story
well cities grow as i say they gain
these returns to scale and they rarely
die cities don't you know in general
they don't die there's some um outliers
but in general they don't
fundamentally you get 115 of the stuff
for 85
of the cost
who wouldn't want that
so
are there other companies organized are
the companies organized around smaller
flats on networks i would argue that
thoughtworks is classically we have been
for a long time we're organized around
these smaller units done by a number of
about 150 to 200 and we split up and we
create newer offices when when we hit
that sort of number
you have to layer in other things on top
right coordination so we all get
together as a big you know as the whole
of the uk will get together every six
months and create those connections like
that and so on but still
i would argue that spotify is a
canonical example
of how to of trying to build a company
around smaller networks these decoupled
teams
teams or squads that have decoupled from
one another um in an organization it's
essentially a social construct with
coordination across here with the guilds
and chapters and so on
some years ago valve or an employer
valve leaked apparently
their employee handbook
if you remember this
the fun thing is in that
they had a diagram of how they're
organized and it's a small world network
they said we want to organize
this way because when we organize this
way we get to go faster we get to do
more stuff we we're more innovative we
create more products
they organize around smaller networks
and finally
going back to those forcing functions
from earlier forcing functions for flow
forcing functions for improving how
stuff gets done that jeff bezos put in
place with the interface rules the
externalizable stuff
two pizza teams
based on the data this is the available
data on revenue from amazon i've posted
an annual number of employees
amazon seems to be doing it as well
as they double in size they get more
than double out
so that's what the 1.15 in that means
so
as amazon gets bigger it gets easier for
them to get bigger the person i was met
in the caribbean yeah this is what he
was saying and if you look at the math
the reason it seems that they're doing
that
is because they're organized around
these small world networks these small
teams that they spin up that are
decoupled from one another it has this
downside i mean if anyone's used you
know apis from multiple different amazon
products like what what's
everything's very different right
they're not optimizing for consistency
across api design certainly
but they're able to add new stuff
really easily on the side
and then add new things that make use of
those products
as they go
as amazon gets bigger it gets easier for
them to get bigger
so coming back to team topologies and
software architecture
you know team topology we've got these
four fundamental uh topologies
optimizing around flow optimizing around
creating teams around small world
networks small teams align along value
streams with direct line of sight of the
customer independent
from others
you'll be pleased today i've nearly
finished
there's a lot of maths for this time in
the morning
you know i said at the start this has
been my journey over the last of 10
years or so you know trying to
understand what the underlying
principles behind microservices and why
they're successful and i think we found
them i think this is what they are i
think it's the idea that we're creating
decoupled teams cohesive around certain
things business capabilities domains and
ddd terms
i guess yeah you know decentralizing
pushing governance down um to the people
who know the most rather than i have to
ask people who you know in their ivory
towers rather than going up the
hierarchy
have have what you need within your team
i think these sort of underlying
principles sort of explain why
microservices
have been successful and i think teams
apologies are basically a handbook a
guidebook and a ubiquitous language
for us to be able to talk amongst
ourselves which is what that's for right
in order to
discuss how to structure our
organizations to improve flow
so social network effects imply super
exponential growth hierarchies imply the
opposite
think about forcing functions for flow
in your own organization think about how
you might take advantage of some of this
research this is the research there's
lots of they're great books and there's
the original papers listed there as well
so that's me for today thank you very
much for listening you've been great
and there's no time for questions so go
get some coffee before the next one
thank you